staying in the nfl standing with
yesterday so i i saw a couple things
yesterday that would just you don't see
in the nfl very often i think this will
be a fun thing to talk about two things
let's play a little game called what's
more humiliating so you have two
different things that happened yesterday
we'll start with the detroit lions
against the minnesota vikings so the
lions are now oh and five shout out to
paulus garcia the world's only lions wow
only self-admitted lion fan outside of
detroit paul you're not gonna like what
i'm about to say so they have this new
coach dan campbell
he made a name for himself at his
opening press conference when they hired
him talking about biting people in the
cavs and he's just weird i don't like
people like that i i don't i don't buy
into it at all i look for someone that
has a little bit more control of a press
conference that wasn't him so i wasn't
super impressed now the lions are having
some bad luck they lost on a 66-yard
field goal to the ravens at the buzzer
and then yesterday they lost on a
54-yard field goal against the middle
school it's amazing how bad luck always
seems to follow around bad teams yes it
is right and certain individuals so here
here's what he did after the game and
david if you could uh play this video in
just one second it's the coach right so
dan campbell after they lost to
minnesota goes into the press conference
right and if you haven't seen this check
it out david can you play this
get off your phone david
here we go
so this is right after the game
they're 015.
just lost that's not the video a little
lower
they lost heartbreaking loss boom right
here
don't worry david it's on we're only
live
it's not a big deal we're just live
we're getting edited we're live
you can't hear him but you can see that
he's crying right he's crying
you know what the hell he's crying
okay
i i just find that so weird so
that when it's troubling
you know you don't want that for them
so
um
that's a guy who's over matched pathetic
prophetic pathetic you talk about losing
a locker room hey these are professional
athletes aren't they supposed to give
their all i mean when you do something
like this you create a standard where
it's saying hey as long as we fight hard
to the end that's good enough you can
cut the audio on it now but i i can't
believe it a total showmanship totally
planned weak on all levels this was
planned kind of
okay what coach goes to a press
conference and starts crying i mean you
could just tell he's inexperienced doing
this but i i just i would be so appalled
if i was a player my coach is going
there crying how about coming up with
some adjustments how about making a stop
so they don't move the ball and get a
chance to kick a last-second field goal
i don't like it
i love this
i if i was a player on that team
i would be so
you you i love seeing this like i i
loved having those
coaches that wore it on their sleeve
they were absolute maniacs but they were
also like huge teddy bears when you
really got to the surface
i if i have a coach like that i want to
go to battle with that guy i want to i
want to
that guy i know he cares he's not
in it for the paycheck he's he's there
like that's a guy like that's not a good
enough actor to show up and plan that
you know i'd want to play for him too
because it's okay if you don't win he's
cool with it man
he battled out there we've really tried
i have a new nickname for him
participation trophy that's his nickname
i i'm
look i understand the theory of there's
no moral victories in pro sports or
whatever
but there are moral victories when
you're a team and you're struggling and
you're and you're so close there's a
time when you're on a team
as a player like just as your own
or as a team
you it's like darkest before the dawn
like you you've done it before you've
been hitting and
man they're not falling but
damn i feel good
like i'm there i'm so close i'm not
getting it yeah and it's so
mentally and emotionally frustrating
when you know you're doing everything
right and i mean maybe you're not doing
everything right but to just have your
heart ripped out twice like that yeah
but yeah but yeah i think it's happening
you're the leader yeah
have your cry in the in the in the
clubhouse all close the door and then
come out and put on the brave face you
know you i don't i don't need to see the
leader of my organization crying after
the fifth game of the year look if this
was the nfc championship game and we we
you know and when we put it all out
there and we left it all and we lost in
overtime man you feel it you feel it for
your people right you feel it for your
guys they went through this it's the
fifth game of the year man this this to
me
is a guy who
is a little overwhelmed yeah and here's
why they say may not have the answers
here's why i say he's faking a little
bit he he he's playing to his audience i
think he's faking it i really like okay
but i'm out here there's a little bit of
of something that was planned there
because his audience is detroit
blue collar yeah which is why you don't
understand underdog mentality hey our
guys are fighters they're trying look
these players need to have
accountability knowing that if they
don't win if they've come this close
you're owen five you can't do any worse
than that and your coach is crying
because you tried hard definitely don't
do that in detroit you do that in la
where people are like wow this is so
progressive he wears his emotions
honestly if you don't do it where the
your fans have a dog
hours in a week
in a ford factory being like oh my
exactly let's not take this crap from
here is it is it is it stop talking have
you looked at our sports teams in l.a we
win at everything everything
he the thing here's what i want out of
my guy and he might be and he he's
probably overmatched he might be
overmatched but i want
i want the authenticity man that's like
i respect helen belichick but i i like
that you know the drone thing where he
just
is a completely different person like i
respect that even though whether i like
it or not
like
i respect that he's up there and willing
to do it whoever hires him as an
offensive coordinator
that's great and they're not saying he
should be the head coach of that team
that's not that's not the general here's
the reality he wakes up the next day and
jared goff is still his quarterback they
still don't have a defense right i mean
you're not a little speech like that's
not gonna change anything nothing
you know and and he thinks he's he's the
hard thing he thinks he's encouraging
toughness but he's creating softness
because like these guys are going to
think that as long as we you know what
it reminds me of last year do you
remember when the raiders went in and
played the chiefs tough right they went
to kansas city and almost beat them they
went toe-to-toe with them and then
didn't they end up driving the bus
around the stadium or doing there was
some side story with that but john
gruden after the game was so passionate
about how hard his guys played and how
tough they were and how proud he was
they lost like five games in a row after
that i just think man in the nfl you
either win or you don't yeah and if your
coach goes in there and crying it it's
it it portrays the software i tend to
agree with that i tend to agree with
that i think especially in football not
other sports in football it's such a
physical fight you didn't just you don't
just lose a game you lose a fight right
you got guys in there that are that are
i mean this is the manliest i mean you
got your offensive lineman that's a bar
fight for 60 minutes and then you got to
look at your coach crying look come on
man like and and if at best zach at best
he divided the locker room right there
because half the locker room might feel
like you're feeling like man i want to
go to bat for this guy this guy really
cares i guarantee you there's some big
strong tough men in that locker room
that are like this dude's a i
don't want to play for this dude my
whole my whole career is is resting on
this guy's shoulders nah man absolutely
not i i see what you're saying let's see
what they play next week
because they can bounce back if they
play
david is what that is so watch him
watch they win a close game like this
when the tables turn and they like carry
him off the field because they can't
yeah bad news though
they're screwed
they face joe burrow and the bengals
next week burro is one of the top seven
quarterbacks in the nfl they got no
chance he's gonna be weeping again at
the end of the game
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]
you